[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله ومعكم ليلى الشيخ
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى الى رام الله الان واجواء
التوتر في الضفه الغربيه على واقع تصعيد
الاسرائيلين احدث حلقاته اعتقال العشرات
في المناطق المختلفه
والى لندن ايضا واليوم الاول من اضراب في
السكك الحديديه في بريطانيا وسط السلسله
من التحركات الاجتماعيه في مواجهه
الارتفاع الحادث الاسعار والصبح سقوط
الثلوج ايضا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
رغم التحرير الروسي واشنطن تستعد لارسال
منظومات صواريخ تويوتا
لدعم الدفاع الجوي لاوكرانيا وسبعون دوله
ومنظمه دوليه تبحث الاحتياجات الطارئه
لاوكرانيا وتتعاهد بدعم يتجاوز الملياردو
دولار
[موسيقى]
خلافات بشان تحديد سقف الاسعار الغاز في
اوروبا تؤدي الى انقسام وتهدد فرص التوسل
الى اتفاق وتقارير تكشف ارتفاع غير مسبوق
للطلب على الطاقه في فرنسا والمانيا ودول
شمال اوروبا مع التدني درجات الحراره
في محاوله لتمرير تعديلات قانونيه تسمح
بتعيين مدانين بتهمه جنائيه ومتطرفين
دينيين في حكومه نتنياهو الكنيست ينتخب
رئيسا مؤقتا من الكود ورئيس الحكومه
المكلف يؤكد ان اسرائيل لن تتحول الى دوله
اصوليه دينيه
في خطوه تؤذن بتحول تاريخيا في انتاج
الطاقه النظيفه بما فيها الكهرباء الكشف
في الولايات المتحده عن نجاح تجربه اندماج
النووي لانتاج كميات طاقه غير مسبقه
ومسؤولون امريكيون يقولون ان التجربه من
اهم الانجازات العلميه وستغير المستقبل
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا سياق ومقالات تصعيد
الاسرائيليين متواصل في الضفه الغربيه
احدث حلقاته اعتقاله العشرات في مناطق
مختلفه لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا طرحنا عليكم السؤال الثالث برايكم ما
هي التداعيات المحتمله لتصعيد والتوتر في
الضفه الغربيه الاجابات
نحو 50% قالوا ان التداعيات هي تصعيد
المقاومه ضد الاحتلال الحين رجعها نحو
عشره في المئه تدخل الدوليا لخفضه بينما
سلطه 40% بالقول ان التداعيات ستكون مزيدا
من التصعيد الاسرائيلي
سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم الدخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
ولقائنا على الملفات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجدات ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
كما تتابعون في الحصاد ليله
اضراب للقطارات يدشن سلسله من التحركات
الاجتماعيه في بريطانيا
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في
الثانيه عشر وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه
يوميات المونديال والتي ترصد بالخبر
والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم قطر 2022
[موسيقى]
والبدايه من واشنطن التي قال مسؤولون
امريكيون انها تضع اللمسات الاخيره على
خطط لتزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ باتريت واضاف
المسؤولون الامريكيون انا واشنطن قد تعلن
ارسال صواريخ باتريات الى اوكرانيا خلال
الاسبوع الجاري واشروا الى انهم من
المتوقع شحن الصواريخ بسرعه في الايام
المقبله ليتم تدريب الاوكرانيين على
استخدامها في قاعده للجيش الامريكي في
المانيا اوضح المسؤولون ان خطه البنتاجون
ارسال صواريخ ما زالت بحاجه الى موافقه
وزير الدفاع لويد اوستن قبل ارسالها الى
الرئيس عليها
ما في لندن فقالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
ان بريطانيا قامت بتدريب 19 الف جنديا
اوكرانيا واضافت في تغريده ان 9000 منهم
عادوا بالفعل الى بلادهم ومعهم مئه وخمسه
وتسعون الف عده ما بين اسعافات اوليه
ومعدات حمايه ومقاومه الشتاء
كما اعلنت الخارجيه البريطانيه في تغريده
ان رئيس الوزراء البريطاني اعلن حزمه دعم
للدفاع الجوي لاوكرانيا في قمه 50 مليون
جنيه استرليني واضافت الخارجيه البريطانيه
ان حزمه المساعدات الجديده لاوكرانيا
تتالف من 125000 مدفع عن مضاده للطائرات
وتكنولوجيا لمواجهه المسيرات الايرانيه
اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
تعهدوا بتقديم اكثر من مليار يورو لكيف
كدعم المالي وعينيا خلال فصل الشتاء
الجاري وكشفت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
لتنظيم وتنسيق الدعم الدولي والمساعدات
لاوكرانيا
46 دوله
واربعين منظمه دوليه من بينها الامم
المتحده
جوزي سالم
لقد وصلنا الان الى جمع اكثر من مليار
يورو بقليل وانا اتحدث هنا عن التزامات
جديده عقب هذا المؤتمر وهي هبه ومساعدات
عينيه مثل ملايين المصابيح وليست عباره عن
قروض ويمكن شحن هذه المساعدات حالا وخلال
اشهر الشتاء من بين المليار يورو ستذهب
نحو 415 مليون يورو الى قطاع الطاقه
ومنذ بدايه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قدمت
دول عده مساعدات بلغت قيمتها حتى شهر
نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي اكثر من 100
مليار يورو صنفت المساعدات الى المساعدات
عسكريه واقتصاديه وانسانيه
وكانت الولايات المتحده تصدرت قائمه
الداعمين اذ قدمت مساعدات بقيمه 48 مليار
نصفها تقريبا من المساعدات العسكريه لها
الاتحاد الاوروبيه التي قدم قرابه 34
مليار يوروها مساعدات اقتصاديه المملكه
المتحده قدمت لاوكرانيا سبعه مليارات يورو
اكثر من نصفها كانت عسكريه كذلك
كما قدمت دول عده مساعدات بنحو 15 مليار
يورو
وينضم الان الينا من لندن براين ستاركس
مدير تحرير مجله الاقتصاد العالمي
والمحاضر في جامعه باكنه
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني للشؤون
الاقتصاديه اهلا بكما وابدا معك السيد
ميلانو
هل انتم راضون في اوكرانيا عن
المساعدات التي قدمت لكم الان في هذا
المؤتمر مؤتمر باريس
كبيره جدا ونحن
ممتنونا للدعم الذي تم تقديمه الى
اوكرانيا ولكن سيكونوا من الجميل ان يكون
هناك التنسيق اكثر وتوقع اكثر للمساعدات
في من ناحيه الوقت والتاريخ
ولكن ااه السيد
براين
الوضع في اوروبا صعب للغايه اييه سواء على
الصعيد الاقتصاد صعيد المشاكل التي
يعانيها منها المواطنين بالنسبه لاسعار
الطاقه وما الى ذلك هذا المبلغ كيف يستقبل
في اوروبا في ظل هذه الظروف
قد
ايه
يراعي هذه الامور
والناس يعانون وكذلك المؤسسات
وهناك مشكله لجوء
والتضخم مرتفع
ربما ان البلد الوحيد الذي يستفيد هو
الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده مستمر
الاوروبيون كذلك يفعلون ومع استمرار الحرب
فلن يكون هناك فرصه لحل سلميه
لذلك ما تزالوا حربا بالوكاله
وهناك محاولات بعض المحاولات لوضعه ضغوط
على
الطرفين من اجل التواصل الى الاتفاق ولكن
ما دام
مدارس الولايات المتحده سعيده بان تستمر
في دعم اوكرانيا فان ذلك لن ياتي بطبيعه
الحال الاقتصاد الامريكي همم لديه ما
يكفيه من الطاقه
والوضع هناك ليس سيئا جدا
هذا الحديث الذي صرح به للتو اا ضيفنا من
لندن يعني ليس جديده في الواقع هناك اصوات
بدات تتزايد في اوروبا بحيث شيء ما تبتعد
عن الموقف الرسمي الذي كان يبدو اكثر
تضامنا ووحده بين الولايات المتحده
واوروبا في وجه همم الحرب الروسيه
الى اي حد هذا يؤثر الان على
درجه المساعدات المقدمه في المستقبل
هم الذين يقررون ما يحدث
في موسكو او باريس او غيرها
الامر بسيط جدا روسيا بدات الحرب على
اوكرانيا قبل ثمان سنوات في 2014 في القرم
وفي فبراير الماضي همم
غزوه كامل نحن ندافع عن ارضنا ونحن نطلب
العالم من العالم باسره ان يضغط على روسيا
لايقاف هذه الحرب والانسحاب منه اوكرانيا
فيما يتعلق باسعار الطاقه هذه هي اعمال
روسيا التي ادت الى ذلك وبقدر استمرار
الحرب بقدر ما ستسوق الامور اذا بدا لانه
من
صعود هذه الاصوات ينبغي مساعدتها في
الدفاع عن نفسها
ايضا
انه اذا استمرت المساعدات ومهما زاد حجمها
فان روسيا قادره ايضا على استهداف المنشات
الطاقه من جديد فكيف هو السبيل للخروج من
هي الدائره
وهذه الدائره من الامر ينبغي ان تخسرها او
تهزم روسيا بطريقه ما
لكن ينبغي ايقافهم صحيح انهم سيستمرون في
استهداف المنشات والبنيه التحتيه
المدنيه ولكن اوكرانيه تتعاملوا مع ذلك
وليست هذه اول مره توجه فيها صعوبات لن
يكون الامر سهلا لكننا نتجاوزها
السيد ترقص هل تستطيع اوكرانيا ان
تتجاوزها بدون موقف موحد من الغرب كنت اشد
قبل قليل ان امريكا ربما تستفيد بشكل اكبر
وان ربما هناك اصوات في اوروبا بدات تشعر
بذلك
هل الغرب صف واحد في موقفه هل سنبدا
بملاحظه او متابعه موقف جديد
انهم سيكورون قادرين على الصمود اكثر بفضل
الاسلحه
لكن من زاويه الروسيه
فان روسيا كان يمكنها ان
لا تقوم بمقامه به لان هذا تحارب بشكل
فظيع
ولكن ما دام الاوكرانيون يشعرون ان هناك
دعما
فانهم سوف
يستمرون في لعب اوراقهم
ولديهم الاموال الامريكيه بشكل خاطئه بذلك
اما اوروبا فان همم تلك الحرب لها ثمن وفي
المدى القصير الشرق الاوسط يستفيد ايضا
بسبب اسعار الطاقه المرتفعه لكننا نريد ان
يكون هناك على قات اكثر استقرارا وقد حان
الوقت
لروسيا واوكرانيا ان يجلس اهل المفاوضات
شكرا لك برنس مدير تحرير مجله الاقتصاد
العالمي والمحاضر في جامعه والشكرا ايضا
الذين
مستشار الرئيس الاوك الشئون الاقتصاديه
مثل الامن القوميه الروسي ديمتري مد بيادر
انه اذا قام النيتو كلام كما لمح امين عام
النيتروجينز بتزويد من وصفهم بالمتعصبين
في كياب بمنظمات بيت رياض مع عناصر القوات
الحلف
فسيصبحون على الفور هدفا مشروعا للقوه
الروسيه
[موسيقى]
وفي تطورات ازمه الطاقه يجتمع وزراء
والطاقه الاوروبيون في العاصمه البلجيكيه
في محاوله جديده
للاتفاق على سقف لاسعار الغاز ويكشف
الاجتماع الخامس من نوعه منذ صيف هذا
العام عمق الخلافات بين دول الاتحاد بشان
طبيعه التعامل مع جمله من تداعيات الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
تماسك الاتحاد الاوروبي في موقفه الداعم
ملكيه لكن التحديات التي انشاتها الحرب
سرعان ما شوشت على حاله الاجماع تلك
المساعدات الماليه العسكريه لاوكرانيا
وفرض حزم العقوبات على روسيا لم يكن اي
منها ليخفي التباين في مقاربه شركاء
الاوروبيين للاسماء
الطاقه هي ما اطلقت التحدي الاكبر
ان حولت اوروبا الى المتضررين من الحرب
وما تلاها من اجراءات روسيه خلصت امدادات
الغاز الى القاره العجوز
اضحى حيويا هنا
امدادات الغاز الروسي دون ان يضارب شركاء
بعضهم على بعض في الاسواق العالميه
في ايجاد اتفاقا يسمح بالمضيق قدما فيما
يخص القرارات المختلفه لحمايه المستهلكين
والمؤسسات الاوروبيه هذا الاتفاق سيحقق
ثلاثه اهداف هي تامين امدادات الغاز
الخاصه بنا وحمايه المؤسسات الاقتصاديه
والافراد في القاره واستقرار الاسواق
الماليه وهي مساله مطروحه للنقاش حيث نريد
استقرار هذه الاسواق
لكن الاوروبيين بداوا حتى الان عاجزين على
التوافق على صيغه لتسعير الغاز لمواجهه
الازمه التي تشتد قسوه مع حلول الشتاء
ليس هناك عجزهم الاول ولا منتهى خلافاتهم
نذكر مثلا ال مقترح المفوضيه الاوروبيه
فرض حظر تدريجي على النفط ومشتقات نفط
الروسيه ردا على الحرب في اوكرانيا
بمنطق مصالحها لم تتح مساحه للاجماع ودون
اجماع قد تنفرد دول اعضاء بخطه وقرارات
التي حفزت ازمه صامته بين بعضها وتلك
اجتهادات غايتها تامين مصادر الطاقه
واسعارها وسياسه نمو الاقتصادي بشكل عام
لكن كثيرين يرون فيها اختبارا اخر لتماسك
الاتحاد وتحديا لديه حاله التضامن التي
اوجدتها في اوكرانيا
اذا المثقله بتحديات اسعار الطاقه وبرد
الشتاء بدت وهي تجتمع في بروكسل لمناقشه
وضع اليه لاسعار الغاز منقسمه على نفسها
لعلهم انطباق الذي رافق قدوم وزراء الطاقه
الاوروبيين محملين بوجهه نظري بلدانهم
بشان وضع سقف لسعر الغاز وصله تحذيرات من
ان يؤثره هذا الانقسام على الاستقرار
المالي وامدادات الغاز لاوروبا خصوصا في
عز الشتاء وخلافاتها مع موسكو نتعرف على
ابرز المواقف والتباينات بشان ذلك في ذلك
منذ الصيف هذا العام خمسه اجتماعات لوزراء
الطاقه الاوروبيين في محاوله الاتفاق على
اليه لوضع السقف لاسعار الغاز بعد فشل في
توافق خلال الشهور الماضيه تقليل اسعار
الكهرباء هدف واحد والوصول اليه لا يبدو
عبر طريق واحد في ظل ارتفاع اسعار الغاز
مع خفض روسيا لشحنتها نحو اوروبا في اعقب
حربها على اوكرانيا يهدد الانقسام
الاوروبي بعرقله اتفاقات مبدئيه سابقه
تتعلق بشراء الغاز بصوره جماعيه للحصول
معا على اسعار افضل ووجود اليه تضامن تؤمن
تلقائيا لدول المهدده باسمه طاقه اما
الاتفاق الثاني فيبسط ويسرع اليه مدح
التراخيص لاقامه الطاقات المتجدده
تقترح المفوضيه الاوروبيه بان تشغل اليه
السقف الاسعار تلقائيا بمجرد تجاوز
الاسعار عاتبه المئتين 275 يورو للميجاوات
السعي لمده اسبوعين متتاليين بينما ترغب
12 دوله اوروبيه بخفضه الى ما دون ذلك
بشكل كبير وهي كل من بلجيكا وبلغاريا
وكرواتيا واليونان وايطاليا
ولتوانيا ومالته وبولندا ورومانيا
واسبانيا واليونان بما اعتبرته استهزاءا
مطالبه بتلين الشروط المطلوبه في المقابل
طلبت عده دول متحفظه على اي تدخل وبينها
المانيا وهولندا والنمسا بوضع بالغه الشده
لمنع اي سقف قد يفعلوا من تهديد امدادات
الغازي لاوروبا فبعض المزودين الاساسيين
مثل النرويج يتخوفنا من سقف يوضع بشكل وق
شجعوا بعض المزودين على التخلي عن اوروبا
لصالح زبائن اسيويين يدفعون اسعارا افضل
ويرى البنك المركزي الاوروبي ان فرض السقف
غير مدروس قد يزيد من التقلبات ويعرض
للخطر الاستقرار الماليه في منطق اليوم
وضع دفع مفوضه لاتحاد الاوروبي لشؤون
الطاقه الى القول ان الاراء والمخاوف
متبينه جدا داعيه للجميع الى ابداء مرونه
اكبر بينما الشددت وزيره الطاقه الفرنسي
على الحاجه الى تامين امدادات الغاز
وحمايه المؤسسات والافراد واستقرار
الاسواق الماليه اما رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه فاعتبر التنازع عدد من الدول
الاعضاء على اسعار بيع وشراء الغاز امرا
غير مقبول مشكله الى ان الشتاء المقبل
سيشكل تحديا اكبر خلافه الغاز وسقف اسعاره
لا تبعد عنها خلافات سابقا بشان وضع السقف
لسعر الروسي واخرى بشان العقوبه على روسيا
التي تبدا اوروبا متباينه بشانها ايضا
[موسيقى]
يتوصلوا الجدد الداخلي في اسرائيل بشان
الشكل الحكومه اليمنيه المتطرفه
انها ستقود اسرائيل الى ان تصبح دوله
اصليه بينما يدافع نتنياهو عن حكومته
ويقول انها ستحافظ على الوضع القائم
وستكون لكل الاسرائيليين
بن تن
[موسيقى]
فقط
او حتى عرضها على الكنيست في نايل الثقه
خرجوا الى الشارع على تركيبتها المتطرفه
يقولون ان التوليفات المرتقبه ستقود
اسرائيل حتما الى ان تصبح دوله اصليه
وقوه المحكمه العليا في وجه التبول
المتوقع للسلطتين التشريعيه والتنفيذ
[موسيقى]
صينيه
ضعيف ويبتز من قبل المتطرفين الذين يريدون
تمرير قوانين ضد الاسرائيليين ضد النساء
والعرب والعقلليات قوانين تمنح السلطه
للمستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه وتقيد
احتياجاتنا وحركاتنا ايام السبت
نتظاهر ضد حكومه من البلطجيه يقف على
راسها بتهم تلقي الرشوه والغش والخداع
وخيانه الامانه وفيها مدان بسرقه سيصبح
وزيرا للماليه هذا خطرا على الديمقراطيه
[تصفيق]
ذهب الى حد اتهام خصومه السياسيين بتحريض
الاسرائيليين على التمرد وعدم قبول نتائج
الانتخابات
التي قال انها ستلتزم بالحفاظ على الوضع
القائم لا سيما بين العلمانيين
[موسيقى]
سنوفر الكهرباء ايام السبت وستكون هناك
شواطئ سباحه للجميع سنحافظ على الوضع
القائم كل فرد يستطيع العيش وفق معتقداته
لن تتحول اسرائيل الى دوله اصليه بل ستبقى
دولتان تهتم بكل مواطنها دون اي خروج عن
القاعده كنت اخذنا لنقود الدوله وفقناه
جل يمين القومي ليبرالي وهذا ما سنفعله
وكان حزب اللكود قد عزل رئيس الكنيسه
الحالي وما نصب مكانه احد اعضاءه من اجل
السيطره على مفاصل العمل السياسي حيث يسعى
نتنياهو قبل اعلان حكومته المتوقع الاسبوع
المقبل الى تمرير تعديلات قانونيه مثيره
للجدل اهمها توسيع صلاحيات شركائه
المتطرفين في وزاره الامن القومي والدفاع
وتمكين زعيم حركه شاس للمتديين الشرقيين
المدان جنائيه من تولي منصب وزاره
في اسرائيل تتشكلوا حكومه يمنيه دينيه
اصوليه لا يستر عورتها كما يقول البعض اي
من احزابي يساري ووسط الخريطه السياسيه
حكومه تثير مخاوف لدى خصوم بنيامين تنياهو
من انها ستقود الى التعميق الشرق في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي لا سي ما بين
العلمانيين والمتدينين
الجزيره القدس الغربيه
الى الائتلاف الحكومي الذي شكله بنيمنه
ياهو من احزاب اقصى اليمين
زادت المخاوف بعد ما نشرت قناه اسرائيليه
ما قالت انها نقاط تضمنها الاتفاق
الائتلاف بين حزب اللكود واحد احزاب
الائتلاف تتعلق ببنود ذات صبغه دينيه
متطرفه لكن اللكود اكد انها مجرد وما طالب
وليست ضمن بنود الاتفاق
جدل يحتزم في اسرائيل بشان ما نشرته
القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه
بين حزب اليكود واتحاد المتزنتين الغربيين
للمشاركه في الاختلاف الحكومي لبني امينه
ياهو حسب القناه الاسرائيليه فين الاتفاق
تضمن مطالب بعدم انتاج الكهرباء في ايام
السبت وزياده عدد الشواطئ التي يتم فيها
الفصل بين الرجال والنساء كما شمل التمويل
الحكومه لمراسم دفن كتب التوراه المتهلكه
التي يحرمون حرقها باي طرق اخرى اضافه الى
زياده عدد المتزميتين في الشركات الحكوميه
اراد لكود ان يحسم الجدل ويتم الى
المواطنين الاسرائيليين فوصف هذه البنود
بانها مجرد ما الطالبه وليست اتفاق وقال
ان اي اتفاق يبرى سيحافظ على الوضع القائم
في البلاد منذ سنين في خريطه احزاب اقصى
اليمين التي تحالف معها نتنياهو من اجل
العوده الى الحكومه نجد حزب يهدى
ثورات اليهوديه الموحده الذي نال في
الكنيست ثمانيه مقاعد وهو حزب يمني ديني
سياسي متشدد تاسس عام
1992 يدعو الى اقامه دوله يهوديه تحكم
القوانين الدينيه ويرفض التفاوض مع
الفلسطينيين والى جانبه حزب الشمس الديني
الشرقي المتشدد الذي نالت اثني عشر مقعدا
في الانتخابات الاخيره يمثل هذا الحزب
الشريحه المتدينه اليهوديه من اصول شرقيه
في اسرائيل
وتتباين مواقفه السياسيه فهو يريد التفاوض
مع الفلسطينيين لكن مواقفه متصلبه في
القضايا التفاضيه اما تحالف الصهيونيه
الدينيه الذي يتزحمه اليمني المتشدد اثمار
بن كثير فلديه 14 مقعدا في الكنيست يعد
امتدادا لحزب كاخ ومنظمه غش ايمو وكان
حزبك معروفا بايديولوجيته القائمه على
التوراه والعنف المسلح لتحقيق امال
الصهيونيه وحتى اسرائيل صنفته منظمه
ارهابيه عام
ورغم هذا الرصيد التاريخي الحاصل بالتطرف
يحاول نتنياهو الخروج من هذه الدائره
بتاكيده ان اسرائيل لن تتحول الى دوله
اصيليه وستبقى دوله تهتم بكل مواطنيها دون
اي خروج عن القاعده
[موسيقى]
الافريقيه الثانيه التي تستمر ثلاثه ايام
وتبحث العديده من الملفات والقضايا
المشتركه
49 من الزعماء الافارقه وانفاضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي الى جانب عدد من منظمات المجتمع
المدني والقطاع الخاص
في وقت سابق عن تطلوعه الى العمل مع
الحكومه الافريقيه لتعزيز مستقبل العلاقات
بين بلاده وافريقيا هذه القمه الثانيه بين
الجانبين بعد القمه الاولى التي استضافها
الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما عام 2014
وينظر كثيرا من المراقبين الى هذه الخطوه
باعتبارها مبادره امريكيه لاحداث توازن مع
الدورين الصيني والروسي في القاره
الافريقيه
قبل الحصاد كنت اجريت ومقابله مع رئيس جزر
القمر السيد عثمان غزالي وسالته عن اهميه
هذه القمه وما الذي تريده الدول الافريقيه
من الولايات المتحده
العالميه وبالتالي للجميع مصلحه
افريقيا
بعقد هذه القمه بين افريقيا والولايات
المتحده
وان- نعمل
قرارات تكون جيده ومفيده للقارتين
ثمان سنوات
الولايات المتحده كانت غائبه طوال السنوات
الثمانيه الماضيه عن افريقيا وعنومها
لم تكن الولايات المتحده غائبه لكن هذه
القمه هي ما نسميها التعدديه الاطراف في
الولايات المتحده لديها علاقات ثنائيه
جيده مع كذب كل الدول الافريقيه لكنها لم
تعمل ضمن هذه التعدديه بل كان تعمل اطار
الثنائيه العلاقات والولايات المتحده
الكثير هو الاهتمامات ونفهم ذلك ولذلك ان
تعقد قمه ولكن رغم ذلك العلاقات الثنائيه
بين الدول الافريقيه والولايات المتحده
جيده
ومثيرها للناقش المزيد من النجاح والتعاون
وان ولايه المتحده
ولا نعرف الصعوبات تعاني منها ونحن نتفهم
موقفها وبالتالي هذه المناسبه جيده
كما هو الحال بالنسبه للدول الاخرى التي
تنظم قمم لها مع افريقيا
كبيره مش الديون عظيمه جدا الان
اما يبدو ان الولايات المتحده تحاول
استماله شركاء لها في افريقيا ها هي تعلن
عن تخصيص 55 مليار دولار لافريقيا على مدى
ثلاث سنوات هل هذا المبلغ كافن برايك لكي
تساعد الدول الافريقيه على تخطي ازماتها
ام تريد اكثر من ذلك
القول ان هذا المبلغ كافي يعتبر مبالغه
ولكن رغم ذلك ان نشكرهم جزيل الشكر صحيح
ان احتياجات كبيره جدا لدينا ولكن رغم ذلك
55 مليار دولار ليس بشيء الهين وبالتالي
اعتقد اننا
الدول الافريقيه
هل نستطيع ان نستخدمه هذا بشكل جيد وربما
نحتاج اكثر منها ولكن ما هو حقيقه هو
الاحتياجات الافريقيه كبيره جدا لانهم
تعرفون اوضاعنا
ذلك
يعتبر جيد يمنحنا نفهمه وبالتالي يبقى
علينا ان نضع الاليات اللازمه لاستخدام
هذه الاموال لكن نحقق نتائج جيدا
ذكرت ان الولايات المتحده مهتمه بافريقيا
والغياب الثمان سنوات من عقاد قمه ليس
الامر المهم ولكن هل فعلا اييي امريكا
مهتمه بما يكفي الرئيس بايدا لم يزر الدول
الافريقيه جنوب الصحراء منذ بدا ولايته هل
هذا يزعجكم ماذا تقراون في هذا التاخر
وان الدول في الدول كلها هذا السياده وكل
دوله لها سياساتها وتطبقها كما ترى سواء
كان ذلك
طبعا سيكون دواعي السرور لافريقيا كما فعل
كثير الرؤساء الاخرون ان يقوم الرئيس
الامريكي بالزياره ولكن لقاءات عن طريق
السفارات
بعثاتهم لماسيه للدول نحن نتعاون مع
الولايات المتحده ضمنها ايطاليين يعتبر
ايجابي وصحيح همم
جيد بالنسبه لنا نستقبل الرئيس الامريكي
في افريقيا هذا سيكون شيء اضافه ان قمه
الغد ست- تنتج عن نتائج كثيره هل يحصل مثل
هذا الامر ايضا
التوقيت الذي ينعقد فيه او تنعقد فيه هذه
القمه وعلى هذا المستوى
ان هذا الامر قد يكون بالصدفه تاتيها
القمه مع ازمه اوكرانيا والتي
والتي
تؤثر على الكثير والكثير من الدول وهذا قد
يكون نحن نعتبر
كيف نستطيع انه ندعم الولايات المتحده ما
يتعلق بما تقوم به من اجل جهود التعديه
العلاقات
لان هذه القمه الافريقيه ستكون لنا جيده
نحن الدول التي نشارك فيها همم لكل دوله
ايضا بشكل
امنيه التي يعاني منها وهذه مناسبه جيد
مناقشه مثل هذه الامور
تقول اننا كا افريقيا مستعدين للدعم
الولايات المتحده هل افريقيا على قلب رجل
واحد في هذا الموضوع هل امريكا او هل دول
افريقيه مستعده
بشكل كامل في ان تقف هذا الموقف
الدول الافريقيه كل الدول بدها سيادتها
السياده وبالتالي
دعم اوكرانيا
والولايات المتحده ايضا تدعمها
لمعرض للغزو لاننا نحن الدوله الصغيره
وهذا قد ان احنا نتعرض له ايضا ولك ليس
هناك مساله نناقش الامر يتعلق بالضمير
اليوم غزوه اي بلدي ليس ليس ليس فيه
القرون الماضيه والتالي نحن نتعامل معهم
همم
متحده
ولم نفكر ذلك التفكير الطويله همم
قمنا باذنته بقوه
[موسيقى]
قلت وزيره الطاقه الامريكيه لعلماء
امريكيين تمكنوا دي اول مره في التاريخ من
تحقيق اندماج النوويه تنتج عنه طاقه اكبر
من الطاقه التي يحتاجها الاندماج اضافه
الوزيره الامريكيه من الانجازات العلميه
الجديد يمكن من انتاج الطاقه النظيفه الى
انه ثمر استثمار الامريكي في المختبرات
والدراسات في هذا المجال
يستويك خلال الاسبوع الماضي حقق العلماء
في مختبر لورانس ليفربول الوطني في
كاليفورنيا الاشعال النووي في منشاه
الاشعار الوطنيه هذا الامر يؤدي الى انتاج
طاقه من تفاعلات الاندماج اكثر من الطاقه
المستخدمه لبدء العمليه كما انها المره
الاولى التي يتحقق فيها ذلك داخل مختبر في
اي مكان في العالم لذلك فان هذا الامر يعد
ببساطه احد ابرز الانجازات العلميه في
القرن الحالي وهو يعزز امنا القوميه لانه
يفتح مجالا جديدا للحفاظ على رافع النووي
امن وفعال في عصر لن يجري فيه التجارب
نوويه كما ان هذا الاشتعال يسمح لنا لاول
مره بتكرار ظروف معينه لا تتوفر الا في
النجوم والشمس
لكن كيف تعمل هذه التقنيه الاندماج النووي
الجديده ما الفرق بينها وبين تقنيه
الانشطار النووي ولماذا تعتبر ثوره في
عالم توفير الطاقه النظيفه
المزيد في التقرير التالي
سخرت الطاقه
لكن لماذا هذا الاحتفاء بتقنيه الاندماج
النووي الان ولماذا تعتبر اختراق علميا
دعونا نتعرف على هذه الطاقه التي يعمل
العلماء في المستقبل ان يوفره كيلوغرام
منها يوميا ما يعادل 1000 ميجا واطن من
الطاقه الكهربائيه لوضع الامور في سياقها
فان انتاج مثلي هذا الكم من الكهرباء
سيحتاج تقريبا الى نحو 80,000 كلغ من
النفط اذن كيف استعمل اليه الاندماج وما
الفرق بينها وبين الانشطار النووي المعمول
به حاليا في الانشطار النووي تستخدم عناصر
مشعه كاليورانيوم تنشاطر الى جزئين او
اكثر وتنطلق النيوترونات التي تصطدم هي
الاخرى بذرات العنصر المشعه وتستمر هكذا
في ما يعرف بتفاعل طار النوويه عند
الانشطار تتولد الطاقه وهذا هو المبدا
الذي قامت عليه قنبته هيروشيما النوويه
وتستخدم مفعلات النوويه حاليا ويبقى فيه
خطر التسرب الاشعاع قائما لاستخدامه
النظائر المشعه لكن الاندماج النوويه
مختلف هو عباره عن اصطدام ذرتي هيدروجين
ببعضهما تحت ظروف حراره وضغط كبيره
ليكوننا ذره اليوم تماما كتفاعلات التي
تجعل النجوما كالشمس مشتعله لمعرفه كميه
الحراره والضغط المطلوبين يمكننا النظر
الى القنبله الهيدروجينيه التي طورت في
الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي هي قنبله
نوويه تعمل باندماج النووي لكن لتفعيل هذه
العمليه نحن بحاجه الى تفجير نووي انشطاري
لتوفير الطاقه اللازمه للانفجار النووي
اندماجيه التفجير النووي للاشطاري سيوفر
كميه الاشعاع اللازمه لتكوين ما يسمى
بالبلازما المشتعله وستسمح الظروف ببدء
الاندماج النووي للهيدروجين اذا تكونت
ظروف تشبه مركز الشمس هنا يكمن سر تقنيه
الليزر الجديده اذ وفرت الطاقه اللازمه
للاندماج النووي بدل توفيرها عبر انفجار
النووي او استخدام طاقه هائله اكبر من تلك
التينتجها الاندماج النووي المطلوب
وستسمح تقنيه الاندماج السميه هذه بتوفير
طاقه نوويه لا يخشى فيها من الاشعاع كما
هو معمول به حاليا في المفاعلات النوويه
التي تستخدم الانشطار نووي والموده المشعه
كاليورانيوم
ومن ولايه شرود ايلندا الدكتور بهرم نص
الشريف معنى الان وهو مدير برنامج الهندسه
النوويه في جامعه رود ايلاند اهلا وسهلا
بك دكتور اذا يعني
لسنوات وعلماء الفيزياء علماء الطاقه
يحلمون بطاقه بديله نظيفه لا تنضب هل هذا
الاعلان يعني اننا اقتربنا من تحقيق هذا
الحلم
اعتقد انه انجاز علميا
كبير الذي سمعناه اليوم ولكن مع ذلك
النظام هندسي يحول يوصل هذه الطاقه الى
الجميع ما يزال على بعد 20 الى 30 عاما من
الان
فقط حتى نشرح يعني تابعنا في التقرير ربما
بعض المصطلحات التي قد يفهمها مختص
بالنسبه للشخص العادي الذي يتابع هذا
التقرير ويريد ان يفهم كيف يختلف الامر
الان وما الذي يعنيه فعليا له ما الذي
سيترتب عليه هذا الاكتشاف
الطاقه يقوم
بيعمل لكم على اجاد تفاعل نووي بين
جسمين ااا نوويين صغيرين جدا
بالهيدروجين وتعرف باسم توتوريوم
والهيدروجين ثلاثه تعرف بتريليم
هو موجود في الطبيعه في الماء
نسبه صغيره من اليوتيريوم
ويمكن ايه استخلاص ذلك واستخدامه
لانتاج الطاقه اما تريليوم فينبغي صنعه في
المفاعل النووي
وبالتالي فان امكانيه
القيام بذلك استخدام هذه
الطبيعه من خلال همم ولكن
ليس هناك منتجات ااا
[موسيقى]
او مهملات من هذه
المصدر الطاقه هذا ولها اول مره
في هذه التكنولوجيا
هناك المزيد من الطاقه ثم انتاجه
وهو اكبر من الماده التي تم استخدامها
وهذا طبعا
انجازا مثير لانه اصبح من الممكن او سيصبح
من الممكن ان يكون لنا همم طاقه اكبر من
الماده المستهلكه لان انتاج الطاقه التي
يمكن ان ننتج منها الكهرباء او الحراره
في النهايه ما يهم الجميع معرفه انت تقول
20 الى 30 سنه قبل ان يصبح ربما قيد همم
التنفيذ او يصبح في متناول
الناس ولكن او 30 سنه الان اا عدد من
الدول الصين الياباني الكل يدخل على الخط
ما الذي يحتاجه هذا الكشف لكي يصبح عمليا
تتطلب اعمال الهندسيه
وان يتم تكثيف الجهود
تم انتاجها واحد كيلوات ساعه
ونحن نستعمل الف كيلوات
ساعه من
الكهرباء
ولكي نزيدها من قمه هذا الانتاج
شو
بواتيس باسبور
من كهرباء لمدينه مثلا او بلد باكمله
ذلك سيحتاج
وقتا طويلا
وما تم تحقيقه في هذا في هذه التجربه
ثمن هو
مساحه ثلاثه ملاعب كره قدم
هندسيا لزياده
كميات الطاقه التي يتم انتاجها
اشكرك دكتور بحره منصر شريف مدير برنامج
الهندسه النوويه في جامعه رودايلاند شكرا
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
بدا اليوم
14 شركه مشغله للقطارات في بريطانيا
اضرابا عن العمل يستمر يومين للمطالبه
بزياده اجورهم وتحسين ظروف عملهم وتستعد
نقابه الممرضين وحرس الحدود وعمال البريد
في تنفيذي اضرابات مشابهه وذلك خلال
الايام المقبله في ظل ارتفاع معدلات
التضخم
وتفاقمي حده ازمه غلاء المعاش
الحركه شبه مشلوله في محطه لندن بريدج
للقطارات غادر السائقون والعمال مواقعهم
مدربين عن العمل 48 ساعه مطالبين بزياده
اجورهم وتحسين ظروف عملهم من بين كل خمسه
قطارات يعمل واحد فقط واوقات الانتظار
زادت الى اقصى حد
جئت من جنوب لندن استغرقت الرحله نصف ساعه
لم يكن الامر سيئا جدا ولكن القطار مزدحم
للغايه اعتقد انني محظوظه
كبيره وهذا ليس جيد لاي احد خاصه اننا
نريد رؤيه عائلتنا تقله
منذ الصيف الماضي والذي ياخذ منحا تصاعديا
في ظل العجزي عن تلبيه مطالب المغربي
يشمل الجميع والاضرابات تنتقل الى مختلف
القطاعات
العدوى وصلت الى المستشفيات حيث سيكون
الاضراب اشد ايلاما
الممرضون سيقلصون خدماتهم الى ادنى حد
ممكن خلال يومين في اضراب هو الاكبر من
نوعه في تاريخ القطاع
الصحينا وتواصلنا مع الحكومه وفعلنا كل
شيء بشان سوء ظروفنا لكنهم لم يستمعوا لنا
والاضراب هو بلدنا الاخير كي نحصل على
زياده ونحافظ على طواقيمنا ونحميه مرضانه
دائره الاحتجاجات تتسع لترجع على جلده
الشهر الجاري ممتلئه بالاضطرابات التي
تشمل ايضا قوات حرس الحدود في المطارات
وسائقي الاسعافات وعمال البريد
تروح الحكومه بالاستعانه بالجيش لسد العجز
في القطاعات الحيويه لكن ذلك لا يزيد
النقابات الا عنادا خصوصا مع دخول فصل
الشتاء واشتداد وقع ازمه غلاء المعيشه
محمد المدهون الجزيره لندن
التي تحاول القوات الروسيه الاستلاف عليها
ولكن
اوكرانيا وتبعد نحو 600 كيلو متر عن
العاصمه كيف
اصبحت بخموت في قلب الهجوم الروسي في دنيا
وتعرضت خلال الاشهر اللاحقه في محاولات
اقتحام عديده احبطتها القوات الالكترونيه
ولان السيطره على بخ متكتسئ اهميه رمزيه
عاليه وذلك بعد الانسحاب من خارف يدفع
الجيش الروسي بكل ثقله مستعينا بمرتزقه
فاجنر وجنود الاحتياط الذين تم استدعائهم
مؤخرا بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه تشكل
ضخمه الحصن
الدفاعيه عن باقي مدن منها تشون فرق
المدفعيه والصواريخ ضربات على المواقع
الروسيه وبينما يستعر القتال انقطعت خدمات
المياه والكهرباء عن فخمه والتي هجرها
معظم سكانها وتعهد الروس بجعلها
مسلخا للجهود جنود
طبعا صراع الايرادات على بخمت جعلها ربما
من اشد
الجبهات
الجبهات القتال طبعا سخونه من الروس
والاوكرانيين خطا لنتعرف فقط على هذه
المدينه اكثر
الى عام
1571 وتعدد اقدم مركز تاريخي وثقافي في
دنياك
عدد السكان يبلغ اكثر من سبعين الف سنه
وبسبب الحرب فقد سر 90% منهم
التركيبه السكانيه تتنوع بين اوكرانيين
وذوي اصول روسيه واقليات اخرى مثل
البيلاروسين
والارنب كذلك
مساحه بخمه تبلغ نحو 40 كم مربعا وتعد
مركزا صناعيا ومنطقه استراتيجيه بموقعها
على طريق الرئيسي يؤدي الى اكبر المدن
اقليم جمباز شرقا
[موسيقى]
لان نستضيف اللواء فايز الدويري من عمان
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك لواء
فايز بخموت لماذا تستعس على رؤوس
في جمله عوامل وجمله اسباب
اولا لماذا روسيا تصر على احتلالها ولماذا
الاوكراني يحاول التمسك بها حتى الرمقير
انت اشارتي الى انها من اقدم المدن 1571
اذا اهميه تاريخيه بالنسبه للجانب
الاوكراني لماذا يدافع عنها يوجد بها اقدم
كنيسه اهميه اقتصاديه تنتج ثلث
الكلوريد الطبيعي الطبيعي 30 30% تقريبا
تتميز بسهوله القمح وعباد الشمس واكبر
مصنع للاليات الثقيله والاهم من ذلك كله
لانها تعتبر البوابه الجنوبيه الوحيد الان
المتاحه للقوات الروسيه من اجل الوصول الى
المدن اللاحقه في دونيسك وحمايه الجناح
الغربي لوجانس لانه اذا ما تم السيطره
عليها ينفتح الطريقتين على طريقه شمال
الشرقي باسلاف يعني ايه سيفردينيسك وهي ما
تسمى او يطلق عليها مجازا مدن المثلث وهذه
هذه المدن اذا ما تم تامين هذا الجناح
لانه مودد من ايه من الايمان ومن ايزيوم
والطريق الاخر سيرافيا ديسك سيفردونيسك
وبالتالي هنا يتم الحديث عن احكام السيطره
الان السيطره على 50% بينما يتم الان
احكام السيطره على اقليم جمباز او ما تبقى
من من همم 50% من همم من الاقليم بصوره
اجماليه اذا جمعنا همم
لوجاست لكن لماذا روسيا مصر روسيا تصر نعم
لاهداف عسكريه لكن همم الذي يوازي ذلك
البعد المعنوي روسيا بحاجه الى ان تحقق
مصر روسيا تعرضت الى ثلاثه انتكاسات كبيره
في قيام في خيار كيف في خرسون وبالتالي
همم ان تعجز عن همم السيطره على مدير
مساحتها 41 كيلو متر مربع سكانها سابقا
70,000 والان لا يوجد فيها الاقل من 10%
القتال مستمر لتقريبا اربعه اشهر وتم
تعزيز هذه القوه
بالقوات الاحتياط وقوات قادمه من خرسون
ومجموعه فاجنر ولا تستطيع تحقيق انجاز
عسكري هذا يؤكد ان الجيش الروسي القوات
البريه هي قوات متهالكه استخدمت كل لديها
كل ما لديها ولا تستحق تستطيع ان تحقق
انجازا ولو بسيطه لي من اجل معنويه الجندي
المقاتل والسياسه المتحدث
هل هي مساله وقت قبل ان يجدوا استراتيجيه
جديده ربما ان الامر يعني بعيد عن التحقيق
بالنسبه
يعني الان تحكمهم مجازا في مصطلح مجازي ما
يسمى استراتييت استراتيجيه الشتاء الان
القدره على المناوره القدره على الحركه
محدوده جدا القدره على استخدام المعدات
العسكريه محدوده جدا لهذا السبب هي
اعتمدت القوات الروسيه سياسه الارض
المحروقه التي استخدمتها في ماريو بول وفي
سفره دونيسك وبالتالي تحاول ان تجهز على
كل ما تبقى القوات الاوكرانيه سحبت
المدفعيه من داخل المدينه الى الخلف لان
القوات تقدمت بعض الشيء ولم تعد هذه
المدفعيه همم بالضروره ان تبقى في هذا
المكان هذا يعتمد على بعدين توفر
الامدادات من همم قذائف همم ام 155
او اللي ما يطلق عليها تربل 7 او الهيمارس
ومدى الاستفاده من فائض القوه الذي سيطر
على
القوات في باكونت تحتاج الى دعم في
البعدين الذخائر والرجال
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
قبل الانتقال الى الجوله الرياضيه يوميات
المونديال
اخفق وزراء والطاقه الاوروبيون خلال
اجتماعهم في العاصمه البلجيكيه والاتفاق
على تحديد سقف لاسعار الغاز واجل الوزراء
الاوروبيون الفصل في سقف لاسعار الغاز الى
اجتماعهم يوم ال19 من ديسمبر الجاري
من قال مسؤولون امريكيون نواشم تضعوا
اللمسات الاخيره على خطط لي تزويد
اوكرانيا بصواريخ باتريات واضاف المسؤولون
انا واشنطن قد تعلن ارسال هذه الصواريخ
الى اوكرانيا خلال الاسبوع الجاري
وعلى الخارجيه البريطانيه في تغريده ان
رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه الدعم للدفاع
الجوي لاوكرانيا بقيمه 50 مليون جنيه
استرليني على وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه انا
المشاركين في مؤتمر باريس للتضامن مع
اوكرانيا تعاهدوا بتقديم اكثر من مليار
يورو لكيف كدعم المالي وعينيا خلال فصل
الشتاء الحديث وكشفت وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه عن وضع اليه جديده سميت اليه
باريس لتنظيم وتنسيق الدعم الدولي
والمساعدات لاوكرانيا
عزل الكنيست الاسرائيلي رئيسه الحليب
وانتخب رئيسا مؤقتا من حزب اللكود في
محاوله لتمرير تعديلات قانونيه تسبح
بتعيين مدانين بتهم جنائيه ومتطرفين
دينيين في حكومه يمنيه برئاسه بنيامين
نتنياهو ومع تصاعدي المخاوف من صعود احزاب
دينيه قال نتنياهو ان اسرائيل لن تتحول
الى دوله اصوليه دينيه
اعلانات وزيره الطاقه علماء امريكيين في
تحقيق اندماج النووي ينتج طاقه اكبر من
الطاقه التي يحتاجها الاندماج نفسه واضافت
الوزيره الامريكيه من الانجاز العلميه
الجديد يمكن من انتاج طاقه بديله نظيفه
انتهى الحصاد شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
والان الى الرياضه في
[موسيقى]
ملح